I can't say if I'm the greatest,...
...however, I'm the first to win a major.
And if that's the bar, then I've set it.
It's thrilling to think that there are a lot of youngsters in Japan watching today,...
...hopefully in 5, 10 years, when they'll get a little older...
...hopefully some of them will be competing on the world stage.
But I still have a lot of years left so they are going to have to compete against me still.
But I'm happy for them because hopefully they'll be able to follow in my footsteps.
I'm really looking forward to the Olympic Games in Tokyo.
If I am on the team, maybe it looks like I will be, I'll do my best to represent my country....
...and hopefully I'll play well.